foreign
[Music]
being able to adapt and improvise is a
big part of what is inherently a
musician also playing multiple
instruments i think is a shirttail sign
that you're talented musically across
the board i would say there's like the
skills and then there's this sensibility
like how people are gonna feel about
your music even like different genres i
feel like i would judge it slightly
differently like if i'm at like a prague
or a metal show and i see some like
drummer or someone just like going him
i'm like hell yeah but if i'm at like a
phoebe bridges concert i'm just like yes
queen break my heart like like struggle
you know
went through a breakup recently so i
wrote a song last week and i actually
wrote on the piano which i started
playing last week so
the stars aligned so perfectly when i
first met you could have sworn that we
would get through
anything
[Music]
but the day light came and washed away
any chance of sanity
i need to be free
to free me from us
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
in
no
oh
[Music]
my
my life
so
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
i'm sorry mom
all right it's all right so
i would say six i thought you were
phenomenal you were absolutely brilliant
this is just
tough because there's six of us here so
that's totally fine five for you and i
thought like your your piano is also
just so brilliant like i thought yeah it
was really crazy four would be i thought
you were sick your voice is great i
would say three
i thought you were phenomenal your voice
is beautiful i would say i'd give myself
two
but then i would give you number one
just because you
the yeah the drums
that's just in my mind so
thank you
yeah i thought he was the man i mean
like i'm just a huge fan of drum the
second i saw that i was like
lit and we have to rank ourselves
oh jeez okay i'm gonna have to give you
a six just because you know i didn't see
a lot of musical stuff songwriting it'd
be probably a different number five
probably one instrument i didn't get a
lot of variety
uh probably four i just saw a lot of
drums i love the drums and you rip but i
didn't get a chance i guess to see like
what else you could do i'll give myself
a three i'd probably give you a two just
for your voice
i'm gonna have to give you one just
because not only did you basically nail
that piece that you played but like just
the expression the dynamic was like huge
dynamics that's what it was that's yes
so good
uh i'm gonna give you the six i mean i i
like it i felt like she broke my heart
too well
she probably like
okay i'll give you the five uh i'll give
you the four so i would give myself the
third i think i'm gonna oh jesus ah i
think i'm gonna give you the two your
piano especially as a pianist myself i
think that's why i vibed the most with
her but just the piece that you played i
was like
wow oh man okay yeah so i guess for um
sixth just the lack of experience i
guess but i love your songwriting
i think it was absolutely beautiful for
five i guess maybe daniel four
i would probably give to sato yeah i
would give myself a three um probably
michael a two and then i'd say mary i'd
give you a one i would listen to you
like in the car on a late night drive i
got head chills when you were singing so
um i don't know if this is like a cop
out i think i'm just gonna give myself
the six cause
is that is that lame just rank yourself
honestly
i'm really sorry i think i'm going to
give you the six the song was like super
moving and beautiful and i would want to
see it so i feel like that discredits
you a lot
in the inside a little bit
i think i'll give myself the five i
think i'm gonna give you the four and it
might just be because i'm in a band and
i'm like always seeing guitarists
i think i'm gonna give
you the three but god damn it you were
so good but i'm also very like pop and
rock oriented and then i think i'm going
to give you second but in terms of like
one of like i think what i would want to
go see on a friday night i think it
would be you because beautiful voice and
solid guitar playing thank you so much
i was literally thinking that i was like
no
this is like
the worst i think we all have an
understanding that in us yeah
songwriting scenario is much different
than like come out here and show your
chops so i'm gonna have to give you the
fix just based off of the fact that i
think if you practice more piano and you
know you get those quote-unquote ten
thousand hours because i think
songwriting and being able to accompany
yourself is extremely important i'm
gonna give myself the five i would give
you the four because you went crazy
like there was like 20 different time
signatures that you were playing right
now like that was ridiculous i think i'm
gonna give you the three i'm gonna give
you the two just because i almost cried
when you've played i'm gonna give you
the one the fact that you can pick up so
many different instruments and play it
so well is something that i strive as an
artist like i want to be able to play
like 20 different instruments
that's all
he not only played instruments i've like
literally never heard of i didn't know
that that's the instrument that's played
in the background of spongebob i had no
idea that he didn't even play all the
instruments he knows
[Music]
[Applause]
number six
is julius
number five is
number two
is mary
[Applause]
[Music]
obviously you know like a little
disappointed i've gotten last because
first your last but it was uh these
people are amazing musicians and
instrumentalists and everything you know
i thought i did a good job i always do i
think i do a really good job of
representing like my vulnerability just
being like as honest as possible i think
i think i did my job i think you know
i'm proud of what i did i was glad that
i got number one for the audience
but i feel like it's very subjective and
in terms of the ranking by musicians i
got four and i was also fine with it
it's how they felt you know and you
cannot really argue with that so
yeah music for me isn't a competition
it's an art form it's something that
makes me
feel like i can express myself and
connect with other people which is
something that has always been super
important to me so
[Music]